li what's the first step in writing a
screenplay first step in writing a
screenplay is making sure that you have
a really solid great idea without that
killer idea it doesn't matter how
technically sound the script is it's
just not going to resonate so you have
to make sure that the idea that which is
the foundation of the script is solid as
interesting as different as exciting a
friend of mine Twain Alexander wrote a
book a few years ago 20 Smith white
calling about his life by his middle
name
Dwayne Alexander Smith Dwayne Smith
wrote a book ten simple rule
rules for writing a great
screenplay and nine of his rules were
somewhat technical and one rule was the
big idea and what he said in that book
was listen I can teach you those nine
other rules but if you don't follow the
tenth the big idea
rule you're not going to have a script
because it really is about and you see
this in the pitch rooms you see this you
know we're now in an event where people
are walking in pitching work that they
started six months ago or a year ago or
a year and a half or two years ago
whatever it is they're walking in there
pitching if they don't have that big
idea to sell nobody's reading the work
because it is about that big idea it is
about that unique character that we
haven't seen before it's about that
world that we haven't been in it's about
a conflict that's unique and different
now there can always been argued there
are eight great themes they've all been
done and redone fantastic
but we're still finding new ways to tell
it to tell great movies take for example
things like I don't like you going back
to Kelly Masterson but before the devil
knows you're dead amazing story
Shakespearean quality fantastic script
totally different amazing look at movies
like Run Lola Run look at movies that
are as simple as boyhood it's a
different way to tell a story and what
we want to see from a writer is what is
your unique point of view what is your
unique story so for me the first and
most important step is picking that idea
that has real legs whether it's for a
screenplay or for a television pilot
what is unique about
what's different about it what's the
same about it so that I can understand
where it fits in it's not too radical
we're not creating whole new worlds but
there is something here that is
interesting to me that I haven't seen in
this form before first it's that then
it's starting to outline to really beat
out an idea and see does it hold you
really have to do those preparatory
steps before you jump into the script
because it's much easier figuring out an
outline if it doesn't work then figuring
out three drafts you know 500 pages in
two years later that you just can't make
it work so you do have to go through
those steps you do have to fix the work
you do have to make sure that it holds
that it has enough promise screenwriting
is ultimately an iterative process
nobody gets it right the first time
you're not supposed to there's a reason
why they call the first draft of AMA
draft so you have to go through those
iterations once you have that idea you
have to to give it the right treatment
in order to get it to a place where it
can be a solid promising full of
potential piece of work that has some
real legs
you